today's speaker is professor brian
keating from the university of
san diego california san diego and he's
the director of the simon's observatory
something near and dear to all of our
hearts now so
um brian you want to take it away
yeah uh how do i sound it sounds okay
sounds great
okay great i don't see myself but that's
okay i know how
ugly i am i don't need to be reminded of
it all the time hi everybody uh
i'm so glad to be talking to you today
this has been
i have to say really a dream of mine not
just since we started this program
uh but ever since i uh became
you know really in just enamored with
the nsbp
and was honored enough to be selected as
an honorary member
uh last year at the uh november
2019 nsbp conference in providence where
i hopefully met some of you
and was uh was just really blown away by
the talent
and i've always had a secret ulterior
motive
which is to get you know first dibs on
the best and brightest people in the
world so
my motives aren't entirely pure guys
just from the beginning i think you need
to know that
and i'm hoping that next year you'll
come out to my lab i'll work with some
of my
experimentalists my theorists my
observers that i get to call friends and
and co-workers out here and it's um it's
just a wonderful place to be
in san diego so i'll be putting in a
couple of plugs and we have positions
available
for all levels of um of scholarship
uh undergraduate graduate postdoc
faculty so don't be shy please reach out
uh and i hope you'll stay in touch join
my mailing list there's a qr code you
can take a picture of that
it should take you to a really special
event that i'll be talking about at the
very end of the talk
so today's talk is going to be a little
bit philosophy a little bit
uh experiment a little bit history and
a whole lot of mystery and i hope it'll
be a interesting story so you see the
title
it says was there a big bang so that's
uh that sounds like a weird uh title to
talk about right
was there a big bang of course there was
right i mean there wouldn't have
been a tv show called the big bang
theory if there wasn't a big bang
but the question is uh the emphasis is
on the a was there a single
a unified a single event that we call
the big bang
and actually we don't know if that's
true and part of what we do in the
simons observatory is
all in an uh attempt to answer that
question
of whether or not the universe had a a
single origin
a point in time before which there were
no yesterdays if you will
and this question is not academic
stephen hawking used to call the
question of
time before the big bang nonsensical as
if you were asking what's south of the
south pole or north of the north pole
to which i told him to his face i said
north of the north pole that's santa
claus
everybody knows that uh but in reality
the question of whether or not the
universe had
an answer to the question of what
happened on the tuesday
before the big bang is actually a very
sensible question
not only that it's an ancient question
it goes back
literally it goes back millennia so i
like to call this
everything new is old again this is just
one example i found from
this is uh you know after you read my
book uh
you know losing the nobel prize you
should read the book of the dead
of kahen samosei which is a gripping
read
it's a page at page turner uh but you
see here this kind of like
depiction of of people moving and this
is i believe in
in ancient egypt uh from 1000 bc
it's just incredibly ancient thing that
depicts an ancient
uh concept of a cyclical eternal
universe
so what does it mean to be a cyclical
we're all raised
as astronomers and physicists to think
about the universe beginning with the
big bang
so what could it possibly mean but
actually the big bang is sort of the
strangest of all possible cosmogenes
ways that the universe could be or
originated because it comes from nothing
literally creation acts nilio
and it's much more kind of obvious to
think about the universe
being cyclic and existing forever and
repeating
time after time for all eternity than to
say there was a single origin of time
and yet most cultures
have inculcated this whether in their
creation nets
or even in our religions um now judeo
christianity
islam they're predicated on a single
origin you know in the beginning that's
the first words in hebrew
very sheet in the in the old testament
what we jews call the torah
means in the beginning and so in the
beginning means there was a beginning
and the question is
was there and that's what we're going to
chat about today
so if we go forward about 2600 years
from the previous
uh slide there was another book that
actually
ushered in the origin of observational
astronomy
and you see these telescopes these were
telescopes used
by none other than galileo galilei in
1609 and 1610 so that's exactly
410 years ago galileo made observations
that would have
a direct impact on how we view the
origin of the universe
and its singularity or lack thereof the
center thing there that kind of golden
thing
is actually the last remaining example
of one of galileo's lenses
so galileo built refracting telescopes
and he used those to understand
properties of the universe and today
with the simon's observatory b2
are using refracting telescopes much
bigger than the ones of galileo
to to predict um uh sorry hold on one
second
i don't know i'm on the phone sound
sorry for the interruption
homeschooling and home uh home homework
take it take precedence sometimes
that little goal yeah if you're lucky
you'll see one of my five kids running
in the background but uh
hopefully i kept them off screen um
because they'll dominate they'll just
take over this presentation
so that lens is cracked and that's an
example of a type of systematic error
uh and not too dissimilar from the types
of things we have to contend with with
the simon's observatory as we build
refracting telescopes that i'll show you
in order to glean information about the
early cosmos
the book that galileo produced in 1610
was self-published it was not
peer-reviewed
and it was entitled the sidirius nuncius
which is latin
for the starry messenger and i used to
think everybody spoke latin you know
it's just like
how are you doing in the streets you
know you'd be talking in latin but
actually nobody spoke latin
and that was intentional because galileo
was not allowed even in italy
to teach in italian because that was
thought to
really have it have an effect that would
influence the
public and perhaps be damaging uh to
catholicism which is of course his
religion
at the time and the pope was a much more
um a dominant
figure than any scientist in history at
that time in the 1600s
what you see in the left is a
fascinating example of galileo's ability
to both create art and science
and use the combination of art and
science
to create emotion so if you look at the
lower
picture there there's a crater like on
the terminator between the light and the
dark side
that's very large and if you've ever
seen a crater in the moon
through a telescope even one as lacking
in power as galileo's just a couple
inches across you saw it on the previous
slide
there's no such crater that looks like
that but
at certain times of the lunar month
galileo depicts things the way you would
feel if you were sitting at his
telescope looking at it so in other
words you didn't see it that doesn't
actually exist but he was trying to
convey emotion
which is something very unusual and we
lose track of that sometimes
as astronomers as physicists that we
what we do has an impact
on society and on philosophy on theology
even
and on these great questions so i hope
that throughout the summer you guys have
had a chance to think about these big
things i've heard you guys are very
philosophically inclined and i want to
encourage you
uh as you go forward never lose sight of
the big picture of why you want to
become a physicist
why you want to become an astronomer
perhaps because these are the really
the most interesting things that we can
study to understand
how does the human race fit into the
world at large
and it's not just through the science
that we do sometimes it's through
artistic
and even emotional uh impact that we
create
so i call this uh the first of the five
great debates
there's something called the great
debate we'll get to that in a second and
that took place a hundred years ago
exactly in 1920.
i'll explain that in a second but i
claim there's been at least five great
debates
throughout astronomical history and they
all started with galileo's refracting
telescope
and we hope to with the simon's
observatory continue this into the fifth
maybe sixth great debate
so what galileo did is he showed that
the model of the universe on the left
was untenable
you could not have a universe in which
the earth was centered
and everything went around it because he
did he observed around the planet
jupiter four stars which we now call
plan
moons of jupiter and they were orbiting
not around the earth but around jupiter
they weren't even orbiting around the
sun but he used this
information to really give data
experimental data
collected with the refracting telescope
that changed the way we thought of our
place in the universe this is what i
call the first great debate and it was
really settled thanks to his data
galileo's telescope allowed us to see
out from
the uh from the from the planet earth to
the realm of
the planets the other planets jupiter
saturn and
uh and now to nebulae such as the
pleiades or subaru which is shown there
the next great debate happened about uh
about
80 90 years 150 years sorry
after those original depictions by
galileo
and that was accomplished by a large
reflecting telescope
not unlike the simon's observatory large
aperture telescope
but this telescope was used instead not
to say where the
earth fit with respect to the other
planets in the solar system but rather
where did the solar system itself lie
within
the galaxy and because of some
pernicious
systematic effects that i'll talk about
herschel
uh put the position of the galaxy
centered on the position of the earth
so our that big blob there is a
depiction of where he thought the earth
lay within the milky way galaxy which is
this irregular blob of stars
and glowing nebula that are depicted
there as well
so this is the second great debate the
question is why
why would galileo and herschel um
make such important contributions and
what types of effects
are there that confound what they were
doing
so the first effect that caused hubble
to
um herschel rather to make his mistake
was that he didn't realize that
that the milky galaxy contains a
tremendous amount of dust
dust is very similar to dust that's in
our apartments our dorms or whatever
it's little particles of
material sometimes it's organic material
like carbon
sometimes it's inorganic like iron and
it absorbs light
and also causes the light to become more
red when you see it
because smaller wavelength light gets
scattered away from the observer on its
way
from this source here at the lamppost to
the observer's eyeball
so the two lampposts on the left and the
right are the same exact distance away
but the one on the right appears farther
away because it's dimmer
and that's a natural tendency and
astronomers have that problem as well
so herschel didn't realize that he was
looking through a cloudy window
in our galaxy and our galaxy contains a
tremendous amount of dust
this brings us to the third debate
which nobody besides me calls the third
great debate
instead we call it the great debate and
that was in 1920
and there were actually astronomers and
they went to washington dc
one named harlow uh shapley the other
one's name was heber
curtis and they had like a boxing match
but it was like a brain boxing match
at the smithsonian in washington dc and
they debated the nature of these
weird blobs of light that they saw
through telescopes
where they actually in our galaxy were
they far away
and now we take it for granted but did
you know that until galileo's time
people thought that meteorites or meteor
showers and comets were basically those
two different aspects of the same
phenomena
mainly something in our atmosphere so
that was half right
but of course we know comets are our
solar system objects they're not in our
atmosphere at all
that was incompletely unknown back then
and the reason why
is because in astronomy we don't have
any depth perception
we can't tell that the one on the left
is actually the orion nebula in our
galaxy
and the one on the right is the
whirlpool galaxy messier 51
and that's tremendous numbers of uh you
know millions of light years away from
earth
so it's tremendous because we don't have
any depth perception
they look kind of similar at first
glance and so this debate
really really revolved around no pun
intended
whether or not we were the center of the
universe or that the universe was really
somehow the milky way galaxy was the
center of the universe
uh the third the next great debate which
is really the fourth great debate
came for courtesy of this first
discovery by hubble which was part of
the great debate of the 1920s
and that was when he discovered this a
peculiar type of star
called the cepheid variable star in the
andromeda galaxy
and that allowed him using a law created
by henrietta swan levitt
that's now known as levitt's law we now
know
that the distance to these objects
they're called cepheid variables which
really
can be determined from counting how many
times they blink on and off or bright
and dark
as time progresses so it's very easy to
count things one two three
but it's very hard to measure distance
like with the ruler using a light bulb
but this is like the light bulb
that tells you how far away it is
courtesy of how many times it blinks on
and off per day
or per week and so hubble realized that
and he took this damage
and he used it to calculate the distance
to the to the andromeda galaxy
he got it way off he actually um
overestimated it by a large factor
which contributes to some of the
controversies and debates we're having
today
called the hubble debate our hubble
tension i won't get into
but nevertheless this type of technique
has been used for 100 years now it's
quite fascinating to think about
how much we know about the depth
perception that cosmologists
and other astronomers lack because of
the two-dimensional
nature of the celestial sphere oh here's
a picture of the andromeda galaxy taken
by the spitzer space telescope
which is mainly showing infrared and
dust emission so this is quite
characteristic of what you'd see at the
milky way galaxy if you happen to travel
three million light years away from
earth and took a selfie
very expensive to do that uh so the next
great debate was really
called the the debate over whether or
not there was a big bang
not just a big bang a single big bang as
i put in the title of my talk but
whether the universe was once in an
extremely compressed
primeval atom state which is what the
father of this model there
essentially a couple of scientists that
came up with this model
and presented it to einstein as a direct
consequence of his laws of general
relativity
and einstein hated it he thought it was
atrocious
and he actually refused to believe that
the universe could have an origin
he furthermore felt that your the
universe was static unchanging
ever more as it appeared to be and in
fact we know now that's not the case
but it took a lot of convincing from
astronomers
theoreticians uh observers and
physicists
to understand what it was like in the
very beginning when the universe was
quite compressed in space and in density
question of whether or not the universe
had a singularity
is an open question and if you leave
here with this from this talk with one
um takeaway other than you know
hopefully you'll be very interested in
all things cosmological i hope it's that
when we talk about the big bang
what we're really talking about is not
time equals zero
we really can't say that we can make a
prediction of what would happen at time
equals zero
uh but what we mean is when did the
first elements form
and those elements form over a period of
about three minutes but it's three
minutes after what
um the question is hard to answer it's
better to think going back in time from
today
we know the universe has a certain age
and just going back in time
and concomitantly going back in
temperature when the universe was a
certain temperature
it was hot enough to fuse hydrogen atoms
into helium atoms
and that was the first process that
created an element that had
more you know neutrons as well as
protons and that was a singular event
in the sense of not in the sense of you
know dividing by a zero
but in the sense of creating a cyst a
perhaps
a mechanism to understand things
according to the laws of physics that we
can test today
so we can heat things up and we can
create hydrogen and helium atoms in a
laboratory smash atoms together create
higgs bosons
but that's only possible up to a certain
energy range
beyond that we have no experimental
evidence for what would happen before it
and the question is what could have
preceded these first few minutes
when these elements were formed and the
best leading
candidate for such an event is called
inflation
and in fact the simon's observatory is
primarily you know at least 50 percent
of its mission is to
look for the signatures of an
inflationary epoch
i'll get into that in a second so what
did the big bang
come to take down what what model did it
attempt to supplant
it was really a cyclic model a cyclic
model is one where the universe
undergoes perhaps continual expansions
and compressions
creating big paddings every so often and
the question is how much does it
compress
down to and whether or not this is true
the implication would be that the
universe would exist for an eternity
perhaps
cycling between compressions and then
bounces
and through expansions and the nature of
this of this event what's depicted in
the center by this dot
that is not at all understood by
scientists
but that doesn't prevent us from
speculating
uh some information started to come
about in 1965
in northern new jersey central new
jersey when penzies and wilson
were trying to not discover something
astronomical they were both astronomers
but they were looking to just to detect
um the satellite transmissions from the
first generation of
man-made satellites that were
telecommunications oriented
this happened in the 1960s and what
they're trying to do is understand why
was there
all this extra noise when they had put
up this precious satellite
called the telstar satellite and they
were receiving tremendous amounts of
noise in addition to the signals that
they could detect from
uh you know generated from the uh from
their telecommunications
transmitters this um
this actual um transmission revealed for
the first time that there was excess
radiation coming in all directions
depicted on the upper orange kind of
blob there
and that the temperature that was coming
to us in all directions had a
characteristic black body
and a degree of radiation of about 2.7
kelvin
and that's famously called 2.7 kelvin or
3 kelvin cosmic microwave background
meaning that it comes to us in all
directions and it can't be created by
a city you know a human generated um a
source of this radiation
that has certain properties and we've
been exploring them ever since
they happened to get this little prize
by the way that's kind of like a gold
star i guess
um so now the question involves that i
call the fifth grade debate
is was there a single big bang that
really started in 1980
with a young scientist named alan booth
i was currently at mit but
he was about to get fired from his job
what we call a post-doc
because he really hadn't come up with
anything noteworthy
to save his career and he had a family
to support etc
it was very challenging for him and so
what he ended up doing
is uh working really hard and thinking
about one question in particular
why does the universe have the
properties it is observed
to have so here's a more modern picture
of what the classic microwave background
looks like and it's not
purely 2.7 degrees in some regions of
the sky
when we look with our telescopes in this
case the wmap satellite from nasa
would see a temperature that's about 10
micro kelvin so 10 one millionth of a
degree
above absolute zero in other directions
above
the 2.7 kelvin so it'll be 2.70001
kelvin in one direction and the other
place it would look exactly 180 degrees
away from that spot
it might be 2.69990 you know like that
and the opposite direction
these are changes departures from
perfect uniformity
by only about 100 parts per million
and it's very fortunate that these
fluctuations occur because if they
didn't we wouldn't be having this
conversation
because you can sort of convince
yourself in a perfectly smooth
perfectly isotropic perfectly
homogeneous universe
there's no place for a particular star
or galaxy to form
and isaac newton realized that back in
the 1700s
and it was part of the impetus that
caused einstein to want to develop what
was called a cosmological constant and
other things
to really understand and explain how can
the universe be so
uh so resistant to change so static
in this case it would be static as a
function of position on the sky it would
be uniform
if not for these fluctuations we would
not be here
because the galaxy clusters that we're a
part of would never have formed
and subsequent galaxies within them such
as the milky way would not have formed
uh so these are places where dark matter
and dark energy
have to have different values and
perhaps they vary in just the right
amount
and without that as i keep saying we
would not be we would not find ourselves
in the universe asking questions about
the universe itself so it's kind of mind
blowing
you stop and think about it that the
reason for our existence
can be our existence can be proven uh by
essentially making maps of the cosmic
microwave background
and then you you might start to get a
question you know in your mind
uh we cosmologists you'll notice this
throughout your career if you if you are
a cosmologist or physicist of any kind
you'll see that there's a problem you'll
see that there's some theory
say the theory of newton's gravity it
explains almost everything that we see
and we deal with on a daily basis
but then if you look closer around
things that are a little bit outside of
our daily experience like the near the
surface of the sun
or near a black hole newton's gravity no
longer
applies and something else has to
subsume it
in this case we wanted to understand the
universe be that led to the properties
of the universe that
led to the formation of the pattern that
i showed you a slide ago which is
reproduced in the upper right where did
that come from
so another takeaway from this talk is
that inflation
is not a theory of the initial
conditions of our universe
so let me say that again it's not
attempting to explain why we have a
universe
for that you need something else it is
attempting to explain why does the
universe have the features that we
observe
today and those questions can be totally
separate and removed
and because of inflation's successful
ability to predict the appearance
abundance structure of clusters of
galaxies depicted below
and even to depict the formation of
ripples and and fluctuations
in the cosmic microwave background owing
themselves
to the pattern on the left upper left
which is called the inflaton field
and so the theory is that at extremely
early times a trillionth of a trillion
for the trillionth
of a hundred milliseconds after uh the
previous cycle of the universe or
perhaps after the origin of time itself
it actually doesn't matter according to
alan guth and other scientists
how inflation gets started what its
initial conditions were
once it happens the characteristic
properties of inflation
become unavoidable so the fluctuations
that lead to galaxies
those were cast in stone or rather they
were cast in the infoton fields
properties at very early times
and so because of that i think it's
extremely important
and fruitful for us to study more about
this and in the year 2001
i came up with an idea for an experiment
that we call bicep
to go and look for these fluctuations
that would lead to
clues about the inflationary epoch they
still wouldn't bring us down to time
equals zero
there's actually a long way between 10
to the minus 37 seconds
as you know there's many decimal places
between that and zero
and that's the important thing that
cosmologists should always note
we are not attempting to explain how did
the universe begin with inflation
we're attempting to explain how did the
seeds of structure that lead to
us being here today arise and that's
still a huge accomplishment
we may never know what happened at the
very beginning of time for one thing if
the universe had an infinite amount of
energy
an infinite density i don't know about
you if
maybe in the q a period or you guys can
interrupt me if you know the answer to
this
is there any example of any physical
quantity temperature density
pressure that's infinite and then that
suddenly
can become finite think about that for a
second
and if you do know an example i'd love
to hear it something infinite that we
know for sure
had an infinite value um uh
and then suddenly trans transfers its
properties it becomes
finite it's very difficult to do even
mathematically
it's not just like xenos paradox or some
kind of cute thing
so moving on this is kind of an update
to the slide i showed about galileo
this shows uh our vision of the cosmos
that we believe today
from earth we can see this pristine view
we can see jupiter
the pleiades andromeda clusters of the
galaxies
the cmb and maybe even back before the
cmb when inflation took place
so that would have happened 380 000
years uh after inflation
and that is owing its properties to the
formation of the light elements
uh that's what we call the big the big
bang remember
the takeaway the main takeaway is
is that um the universe can have
a beginning of time which we don't
understand but we know for sure what
happens when nuclei start forming
because i can go down to my neighborhood
laboratory and smash atoms together and
reproduce the temperature and density
um so the next thing so there's a chat
let me see
i think joe said something yeah joe
roberts life equals infinite value that
yet finite
yes that is that is absolutely true i
believe all of human life
is equally infinite in value infinitely
precious
um hopefully won't get taxed infinitely
but uh but yes i agree with you
but in terms of and i believe infinite
potential of every human being
i'm lucky enough to be the father of
five young children
and every single one of them has a
different universe within their minds
it's just
incredible i agree with you so where are
we
well in science it's really good it's
kind of like
if you had a team sport i don't know i
used to play uh play baseball
and when you played like the best teams
that was always the most fun
because they would really give you a run
for the money uh and and it would just
be much more exciting
so it would be really sad if like the
big bang had no other competitors to
its to its properties because there
would be nothing for it to lead to
improving itself
and we say iron sharpens iron or steel
sharpened steel the smarter
the better your opponent so to speak it
always tends to be friendly and in good
nature
but the more advanced you could push
yourself you get so much better and it's
better for
humanity it's better for cosmology so
there was a healthy amount
of competition for the big bang to a
single big bang
and they go by different names the
quasi-steady-state cosmology
the inflationary multi-verse is a theory
that comes allied with the theory of
inflation
that you must have a multi-group and
that's really exciting uh it's topic for
another time
but it's one of the things that would be
an inevitable this um
a conclusion if the simon's observatory
is quote unquote successful and i don't
like to say it
so i put the air quotes around it but
you never want to be as a scientist and
i hope you'll take this away too
that you never want to prove something
you never want to be in that position
where i have to prove something i'm
going to get
like a tenure you have to prove
something you're not going to win a
nobel prize
like you want to discover things but you
don't want to have to prove them why
because the propensity for the human
brain to be biased
to suffer from invidious prejudices to
discover something it's very hard to
dissociate yourself from
your need on a personal as a human being
from what is scientifically true or not
so always being on guard against that
and it's something i have to confess and
i'm ashamed to admit
i wasn't so good at earlier in my career
as i'm about to explain
but this leads to you know kind of where
we're at these are the different
alternatives they all have pluses and
minuses and our job as experimental
scientists and observers and theorists
is to explore the consequences of each
one
and then see where the data takes us so
a bouncing model
this is kind of a cool animation of this
from quantum magazine
where you kind of go through a collapse
and then an expansion a collapse and an
expansion
one of our colleagues who is uh assist
us with the simon's observatory he's not
a member of the team
but his colleague and the aegis is um
they explore these bouncing cosmological
models
and i can give links uh later on for for
folks that are interested
this is an alternative to inflation
there's another one by sir roger penrose
so suraj wrote the first book
that i ever read in popular science
called the emperor's new mind
is about computers artificial
intelligence can
a computer ever think and pass the
so-called turing test
and i was honored that he when i wrote
my book he gave my book an endorsement
so that was you know kind of like 30
years later
uh just such an incredible treat so
there we are
talking about his book and his uh model
he has a model called the
uh cyclic conformal uh cyclic cosmology
where the universe goes through a series
of big bangs and kind of
um big chills and uh over time the
universe's properties leading to
a um an essential mathematical
property called a conformal rescaling
that takes
the big bang of one universe in into a
big crunch of another universe
it's quite complicated he does describe
it on a couple of my podcasts with me
uh that i'll refer you to uh it's it's
it's less explored than inflation
that doesn't necessarily mean it's
incorrect so the idea is to keep an open
mind
and explore the implications of all
these theories
the multiverse is kind of inflation's
original
um original seed which is that inflation
is really the initial conditions uh
sorry the multiverse rather is the
initial conditions that allow the malt
that allow the inflationary universe to
to occur so there's actually potentially
an infinite number of universes so when
i was a kid and when most of us were a
kid the universe meant everything there
is
but actually according to some we should
talk about the multiverse and not the
universe and that the universe is a
special case of the multiverse
but essentially what we can observe in
our universe those cmb
spheres are only a tiny tiny
infinitesimal fraction
of the possible number of observable
universes that our life could have
our universe could have existed in but
we can only
exist and we as human beings as
conscious cosmologists
may only exist in universes that have us
a property called a small amount of
vacuum energy
which i don't have time to get into but
it's kind of a fine-tuning argument that
we exist so we can only exist where we
can exist to ask the question of
why do we exist not super satisfying
some people don't like philosophy
i like it but uh some people get angry
out of philosophers
um so in 2001 we i pitched this
experiment
to go after for the first time a pattern
called this curling twisting
uh b mode polarization pattern that i'm
depicting on the upper right
and that would result from these
gravitational waves which themselves
would result from inflation
which itself would result from the
multiverse so you see the chain of logic
starting on the right if we were to
observe this curling twisting pattern of
microwaves
we would infer from that that there were
early amounts of gravitational radiation
the only known mechanism for this
everybody admits is something called
inflation
and the only way to get inflation
started is to have something called the
multiverse
so it's an incredible impeccable degree
of logical steps
to go from an observation that we may do
with bicep
or with the simon's observatory back to
this concept that there could be an
infinite number of copies of you and i
right now throughout something called
the multiverse
it's mind-blowing to think about it
that's what we get paid to do
this is what cosmologists get paid to do
and it's such a fun fun
incredibly active thing to do um i just
love it i can't i can't see doing
anything else
but don't tell my boss not because they
may say well you'd work for free so
so the process by which we observe it is
called polarization
i don't have time to get into that i do
talk about in my book i want anybody who
sends me an email
with your shipping address i will send
you and joins my email list
um so at brianketing.com i'll send you
guys a copy of my book i don't know if
casey did that already casey do you guys
send a copy
okay so i'll send you guys a copy of the
book join my mailing list
and i will so it's briankeating.com and
there's a pop-up for my mailing list
i'll send you not only
i will not only send you a cup of the
book i will send you the villain
of my book there's a piece of dust and
you'll see what that means in just a
second
so we look for polarization i describe
it in the book again i'll send it to all
you guys
uh just go to my website because
otherwise i'll forget um
the bicep2 telescope is designed to look
for this and as i said early on
it is a refracting telescope i'm
convinced if i could go to my colleagues
in biology or some of you guys know a
lot about biophysics
and you could resurrect galileo that i
could show on the telescope and say holy
cow this is exactly what i made
410 years ago and it's exactly what
we're doing at the simons observatory
too
we're cooling down a telescope near to
absolute zero we're outfitting it with
very special detectors called transition
and super conducting detectors
we're measuring making many of them they
operate near absolute zero so that's one
thing he probably couldn't
fully understand because they didn't
have that concept back then but he
understood he made thermometers that
were very accurate
he was an incredible scientist but he
had his biases he had his prejudices
he believed that the tides that are
present on the earth's oceans
were caused by the motion of the earth
around the sun combined with the motion
of the earth on its axis
we now know that it's completely wrong
they had nothing to do with that
they only are caused by the earth's moon
but because he wanted to prove that the
earth was in motion remember i explained
that earlier
to prove copernicus was right he came up
with this cuckoo
model that the earth's tides were like a
bathtub sloshing around during an
earthquake or something here like
and it was because of something you know
uh called confirmation bias
you always have to be on guard about
that
so this is what bicep 2 looked like we
built it in california we shipped it
down to the south pole
south pole is a very center of
antarctica
and i got to go there twice and i wasn't
the first person but i went there
almost uh less than a hundred years
after the first people got there
uh first team was a norwegian team led
by roald amundsen the second team was
robert falcon scott all the men that you
see here unfortunately
are dead or died well everybody's dead
but from 105
seven years to ten years eight years ago
but actually these guys died on the way
back
um because they didn't uh they didn't
pack enough food basically
uh speaking of food if some people like
uh chicken
some people like fish if you can't tell
the difference between chicken and fish
you can always have a peg now you can't
eat a penguin it's totally illegal
but my kids love penguins i brought back
some penguins stuffed penguins for my
kids
but you see they're not actually the
cute cuddly creatures that people think
of them as
so they're pretty nasty creatures uh but
maybe they're only mean to other
creatures like i see my two
daughters you know they'll fight like
that sometimes my three boys will fight
like that
maybe they're just not nice to other
penguins maybe they're nice to
scientists like
me and so this picture shows what
happens if you get a little too close to
a penguin
okay so that's life in antarctica it's
still very dangerous luckily i didn't
die down there
and actually it's very nice so there's a
huge station down there it looks like
the ice planet hot
from star wars you go there you have an
ice base you have your own room
uh that's the axis that kind of golden
thing here
is the axis in which the earth is
turning so the earth is turning and this
is where it comes out the southern side
of the planet
it's really fantastic you go there you
go take a selfie you gotta check in on
instagram
etc uh and that's bicep that's what
bicep was it's the building that it's in
you can't actually see bicep itself
and that's the outhouse that's very
important building trust me
we did detect that swirling pattern of
microwaves in 2014 on st patrick's day
we announced the detection of a swirling
twisting pattern of microwaves
huzzah that's what we wanted to detect
right that's what we were
hoping to detect we've detected
inflation
so we got a lot of attention in the new
york times
the san diego union tribune cnn uh this
is
around the world everywhere space ripple
seen as the big bang smoking gun
remember this would be evidence for
essentially the inflationary origin of
the universe and the multiverse
so uh what else could it be you always
have to ask yourself what else could i
see
if it isn't the sign signal that i'm
looking for so it turns out i'll skip
over this because we're running a little
low in time
but there are other things in the
universe that can produce this b mode
twisting pattern of microwaves
some of which is related to the very
types of phenomena
that are more familiar to us forms of
meteorites and meteor showers when a
star explodes
it often produces metallic objects that
are highly magnetizable like iron
cobalt and nickel and they can swirl
around in our galaxy
sometimes they form planets but the
planetary formation
process is not 100 efficient so there's
a lot of leftover schmutz in the cosmos
as we say
and some of that can pollute
astronomical measurements making the
dust that confused herschel
and hubble and others and so what does
that look like under a microscope it
looks like this this is a scanning
electron microscope
and these magnetizable particles can get
twisted up in the milky way's magnetic
field
and soon after our announcement just six
months later we basically had to retract
our discovery so imagine how
embarrassing how frustrating even
humiliating that felt
just to really be considered for you
know the highest awards and accolades
possible and the
greatest discoveries of all time and
then have to retract it
so it's a story of also being humble and
and understanding
what it is you're up against and so now
we and the simon's observatory and my
friends on the bicep array project
are working hard not only to measure the
signals that we quote unquote want to
see
the ones that could take us to stockholm
sweden but
instead also see the stuff that nobody
wants to see the dust the dirt the
schmutz the
the stuff that you want to get away from
and so
one of my friends uh and if you again go
to brian keaton.com
after this talk sign up for my mailing
list i will send you a chunk of stuff
and one of my uh readers i sent him a
chunk of it
he happens to have an x-ray spectrometer
at his uh he's a professor at farming
daily university long island
where i'm from originally and he did a
chemical
uh assay of it and it shows that most of
its iron cobalt
nickel and uh trace elements and other
stuff which is probably dirt
that's found on it so you see but these
things are actually the same things that
are made inside of supernova
cataclysmic explosions they get aligned
by the cos
the galactic magnetic field and they
produce a twisting pattern of microwaves
so actually the universe doesn't look
like this it doesn't look like pristine
at all it looks like this
which is as san diego and i say this
looks like los angeles on a good day
it's pretty smoggy it's pretty smutty
it's smoky city schmutzy
so you want to know about that now you
have to go out and measure it
oh by the way yes certain other things
got blown away as well
so um what do we do next well we go and
we look
not only for what we want to see namely
inflationary b modes
but also for dust to do that we need to
develop the simon's observatory
which has many many members of it and
you've probably gotten to interact with
them
throughout this past summer and we hope
we're going to continue to interact with
you
for the foreseeable future so where is
the simon's observatory it's in the high
atacama desert
of northern chile at an elevation of 5
200 meters
it's above half the atmospheric pressure
that we feel on
sea level elevations you see the site
there
it's made possible by a generous
donation
from jim and marilyn simons their
daughter
elizabeth simons and her husband mark
heising
as well as all the partner institutions
that do contribute to it
so what is the science observatory well
it's a collection of
now we're at 300 people it's quite a
vast assemblage
of human brain power casey's in there
somewhere i'm trying to find my cases
uh um right in the center taking up all
the space
um so it's a giant space super sucker
that's what we want we want to suck up
that no i'm just kidding
um i always joke you know we have to go
into space we have to suck up all the
dust
uh it's actually the sixth decade of the
dust buster which i can't believe i
remember when the first one came out
so what are we doing with it we're
trying to measure uh dust as well as the
cmb
and we're trying to measure it with high
precision and accuracy from the site and
chilling
we look for foregrounds we're not
ignorant of them we characterize their
behavior
and we do so with two different types of
technologies one is a large six meter
diameter telescope shown here
there's the actual diameter of the
receiver the upper thing in the upper
right
this thing is 50 feet tall the whole
thing can pirouette on its axis is quite
amazing
then we have three small telescopes
which are being built
i have links i'll send them actually on
my website
on my youtube channel rather we can you
can show what they'll see what the
status is because we're running along
time
but i want to come to the very end and
talk about what do we know and what do
we know that we don't know
and always ask yourself questions about
that so
is it possible to prove your idea wrong
i always get emails once once a week i
get an email by casey gets an email
uh dr wagner dr keating
i've got this theory and it's einstein
is wrong by the way
and if you help me prove it i will share
my nobel prize with you
and i always say you know that's that's
really nice but um you know can you
prove yourself
wrong can you show that you know that
you're not right or is it a no-lose
situation for you
and you know then they always make these
noises that some of my kids are making
in the background
we start crying uh but no they don't but
they never answer that question but
actually
a fun fact i interviewed um uh adam
reese
who won the 2011 nobel prize for the
discovery in part with his collaborators
that the universe is accelerating i told
him that story asked him do you get
these same things
and he said yeah i got emails all the
time and you know that they'll share
their
mind that they're not prized with them
and he said that's how i got my nobel
prize
to begin with he was just joking of
course so there are all these different
models and always ask can you prove them
wrong
because otherwise you can't actually be
confident that you're not seeing some
other manifestation of something
that is completely unexpected so be
careful when you hear a theory if it
can't be proven
wrong it may not be able ever to be
proven right
in a sense in the same way that you'll
never be able to get data that the
multiverse exists
because any possible combination of
evidence can be evidence for the
multiverse
on the other hand if you can prove that
inflation took place
it may be that inflation took place but
the but the multiverse is wrong
so sometimes learning something about
the inadequacies of your theory
allow you to find things more refined
and improve your prediction
and your predictive ability